bien des personnes engagement et d'avoir
la confrontation visuel jusqu'à pour
comprendre les deux c'est plus accepter
finalement ce qui est à lui et non ses
45 ans leur bail est personne qui pulse
est d'avoir le quart d'heure de leurs
proches comme une étape encore plus
difficile justement nous on quand on est
arrivé à lac-mégantic on se dit il ya eu
un avant et un après finalement en
parlant avec presque tout le monde on
s'aperçoit que non ici on est encore
dans le pende c'est faux la page n'est
pas tournée avez vous la même impression
et leur nombre et la taille et aussi
longtemps qu'on n'aura pour retrouver
notre jeu baptisé amoureux auraient
stinat le pain de vie j'ai l'impression
que ça va prendre quelques années encore
un emprunt il cessa passé à l'après nous
on aime avoir notre basse estimé début
juillet on va devenir un peu plus mal
après au niveau des infrastructures mais
en vendant le pain d'accord parce qu'on
avancera soit pas fini de travailler
donc on veut rester avec
cimetière de terre de vins chill ou pas
encore
c'est une cicatrice qui celui là pour
toujours là mais ça va prendre de
nouvelles constructions nouvelles aides
aux attraits pour pouvoir les sécuriser
ce qui est en arrière on peut parier
change on pourra essayer d'avoir assez
pour réussir à sortir pour justement se
sortir tout le monde de ce qui arrive
puis si on le fait pour ben on va tout
coup les cas qu'on veut avancer mais fou
regarde en avant un faux pas car dans
l'ariège le recul ans à vama évidemment
mais ça va mieux même si il ya des
obstacles c'est un peu un mot qui
représente bien ce que vous souhaitez
pour vous pour votre communauté
c'est la dynamique c'est le vouloir
cesser de travailler positivement et non
pour toujours être négatif vous faut
travailler pour l'avenir pour l'avenir
me faut regarder ça d'un bon avec vous
arrêter parmi eux qui disent pas trop ce
qui s'est passé mais fouassier d'avancé
puis de trouver les solutions pour ça se
resserre